mr. Church stars Eddie Murphy and is a
story of a true friendship according to
the writer of this film and is about a
very talented chef played by Murphy who
also has quite a bit of Secrets he
agrees to work for a family when their
mother is dying of cancer and the young
girl who grows up to be Britt Robertson
eventually becomes great friends with
this man and it's really about their
bond about how they change each other's
lives and the story that unfolds because
of that Eddie Murphy is one of the most
talented performers alive I genuinely
believe that this guy has been hilarious
for years and unfortunately has made a
lot of really bad choices when it comes
to movies but he recently came out
saying that he didn't want to make any
more terrible comedies like Norbit he
wanted to focus on making better films
and he's had a four-year hiatus of
nothing so I was pretty excited to see
what he could do in mr. Church and I can
tell you without a doubt he is the best
part of this movie he's fantastic in
this role and I loved seeing him give a
nuanced performance a very quiet subdued
performance a performance that was able
to speak quite a bit without him
actually saying anything because he is
very subdued as a character in this
movie he holds a lot of Secrets and a
large majority of this film's suspense
is built off of what he actually does in
his own free time because we don't know
for so long and his character and his
performance easily are the best part of
this movie because most everything else
about it just does not live up to what
Eddie Murphy is doing on screen save for
Britt Robertson who once again is very
good in this role as the daughter who
grows closer to this man the
performances are not the issue here
they're all top-notch my issue is the
storytelling this is a script with a ton
of narration I mean it basically feels
like you are watching a novel being read
to you through audiobook form and I'm
not one of those guys that's like oh
narration is bad
narration shouldn't be in movies is
cheap and lazy and easy
narration sucks one of my all-time
favorite movies features a lot of
narration American Psycho and if it
works it works in this film
unfortunately when you are panning on a
character and she has an expression that
makes you want to understand what's
going on in her head you unfortunately
don't have those feelings because as
were
in on this character we have a narration
that tells us everything she's feeling
there's no sense of discovery in this
film because every time someone is being
emotionally subdued in some way or
someone shows up at someone's house or
the scene doesn't understand how to let
us know as an audience what's actually
happening the narration is used as a
crutch to explain to us the things that
are on the screen and so we don't feel
like we're discovering emotion with
these characters the storytelling just
doesn't live up to the performances on
the screen the storytelling is so rote
and familiar and very predictable there
wasn't a single surprise in this movie
and a lot of it does get very sappy and
extremely melodramatic and not that
there's necessarily anything wrong with
the melodramatic movie or a more
emotional scene that maybe pulls on your
heartstrings and might be a little
emotionally manipulative this entire
film feels that way unfortunately I
think mr. Church would have actually
been a lot better as a book in fact a
lot of the narration feels like novel
dialogue it doesn't necessarily feel
like script dialogue where the way
someone would actually talk which is
very unfortunate because Eddie Murphy
really is giving one of the best
performances of his entire career in
this movie but this film has no idea how
to utilize him at its core though I was
very charmed by the friendship that is
portrayed in this film it's just a
really sweet friendship and that's the
best part of this movie along with Britt
Robertson and Eddie Murphy's excellent
performances unfortunately the movies
story kind of crumbles within itself and
it's incredibly predictable I'm gonna
give mr. Church a C this is a harmless
movie that I think most audiences will
really enjoy it's just that the
storytelling could have been
considerably better guys thank you so
much as always for watching and please
check out audible.com slash Kris they
have so many amazing choices of
audiobooks on that website hundreds of
thousands of things I've personally read
a lot of the Star Wars books on this
site you can listen to so many of these
Star Wars novels or other novels on your
mp3 player your computer your tablet
wherever you want and if you go to
audible.com slash Kris you can get a
free 30-day trial of audible through me
thanks to audible so I really appreciate
audible for sponsoring my videos
definitely check out on
calm / crisp you guys are the best thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]